Let me illustrate the use of signifiers. How
do you start and stop this video? Feel
free to experiment. See that right pointing triangle,
down there? That's a pretty universal symbol, to
mean play. Click on me to play the video. And when you click on it, it
changes to two vertical bars. Again, pretty universal
symbol for pause. Click on me to stop
the video. Now, how would you know that, before you ever experienced
it? Usually you have to be told. Or sometimes they label it, play and pause.
But once you've learned it, it's the same all over. So that simplifies things.
But hey, there's more. Click any place on the screen, it stops the video.
Click again, it starts it. Pretty neat, huh? But no visible signifier.
How would you ever learn that? You just have to know. Oh, and while you're at
it Double-click. What happens? Hm. So what
do you think? These invisible signifiers that
make it easier to do the thing. Is that good design, or bad design?